all the focus is on the president's
remarks about s whole countries but one
simple question can we really trust
anything said by senator dick durbin
come on even the Obama White House
called out Durbin for inventing a quote
denying the Democrats claim in 2013 that
a GOP House leader told the president
quote I can't even stand a look at you
close quote
Obama's press secretary at the time Jay
Carney responding I looked into this and
spoke with somebody who is in that
meeting and it did not happen and here's
a look back at another shocking
statement from the Illinois senator if I
read this to you and didn't tell you
that it was an FBI agent describing what
Americans had done to prisoners in their
control you would most certainly believe
this must have happened by Nazis Soviets
in their gulags or some mad regime Pol
Pot or others for reaction let's bring
in former Republican congressman and
House Oversight Committee Chairman jason
Chaffetz from Utah and in Atlanta
Georgia
Elena Georgia former Obama regional
campaign director robbing Bureau Robin
let's let's start with you on this I
remember back in 2005 that dick Durbin
comment about our troops because my
producer at the time Lee Habib was
watching it was c-span I think was at
night if he calls me he said did you
just hear what Dick Durbin said he
describing our guys like Pol Pot Nazis
and he ultimately had to come out and
apologize but that statement I can't
imagine ever making a statement about
the US military such as that that one
statement told me more about dick Durbin
than anything else that you can point to
about something that that Trump said
about certain countries that send a
disproportionate number of lottery visa
holders to us your reaction my reaction
well I appreciate you bringing up that
statement I'm a veteran Army Ranger from
the 75th Ranger Regiment I had the honor
of serving so you know I do I was a very
much offended by that statement
politicians say the darndest things and
Donald Trump is
now a politician and he is one of those
people saying just the most things do
you think Somalia Sudan and other
countries that send people here that
send their people fleeing do you think
their paradise do you want a vacation
there I mean tell me what you're
offended by you talk about Donald
Trump's comments from yesterday yeah
thought about those countries well my
thought is just the recklessness that he
uses when he says these things
my main concern I got as a veteran I've
got a lot of friends that are Trump
supporters I'm concerned because that
debt statement however you cut it came
out as overtly racist to a lot of people
there are so many principle there are so
many it came out that way because the
media wants to fulfill J hold on once I
can get back to you Jason they've been
playing the race card over and over
again I submit they're out of ideas your
reaction no I think that's right in part
in my voice here fighting a little a
sore throat but no it's the only thing
they have look there were six members of
Congress in that room there's only one
Democrat and only the Democrat is saying
that this has happened and I think it's
highly suspect when Dick Durbin who has
a history of doing this I mean he said
he used this card on on Republicans
before was absolutely wrong and I think
it was a German philosopher Nietzsche
who said I'm not upset that you lied to
me I'm upset that I can never trust you
again and that's the reputation that
dick durbin has earned in this situation
and it's just absolutely wrong what he's
saying when the president is saying no
that didn't happen not and all the great
results for the african-american
community as well gentlemen sorry the
segment sure